thibault souviens très bien chasser bon
ça change aussi raison ajouté vous et
sur vos impressions ce festival on a
l'impression d'un chauffe et il va
chauffer rappelle t il allez bon
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors tu vas nous
dira j'ai un contrat avec un grand
boxeur way est superbe et je vais
pouvoir aller te paie ton pierre
aucaigne c'est vrai entre lui et la
mutuelle sérieux les deux là d'un coup
[Musique]
c'est génial style c'est trop bien trop
bien c'est encore un piano ouais qu'à
moi tu exerçais tous les jours sur un
piano admis non c'est génial steve jour
dans les habitudes de pouvoir faire des
études
est ce que tous les bras alors c'est
quoi c'est un combat non c'est pas des
combats
j'entraîne un type qui s'appelle tac
mbarek c'est un champion qui est têtu
l'a vu sur youtube déjà oui c'est celui
qui sont avec un nombre croît la voix
chantée la chanteuse même que je veux
c'est dans la pub [ __ ] montré hier
soir c'est toi je suis avec lui et tulle
entraîne voix
j'ai à faire son sparring ouais un peu
tu te fous de ma gueule non pas de
pagaille
steve tu m'a toujours dit que tu ferais
jamais le pari c'est très bien payé j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] civ depuis que je te
connais tu me dis que sparring c'est
plus d'argent que faire des combats par
k o
est-ce qu'il ya que paris
sa cause la dernière fois sinon ça je
m'en fous bah non c'est quoi le problème
oh c'est quoi le problème
quand les gens te regardent ils sont
contents que tu es mal tout ça on s'en
fout de ça moi je m'en fous pas
tellement perte de temps ou alors que je
suis mdr
je veux dire que ce parent que c'est
important pour moi et ma famille stop
stop stop je sais pas les restos du
coeur mais j'ai un championnat d'europe
à préparer tu vois ça c'est sérieux
c'est mon retour j'ai pas le temps des
états d'âme ce combat là il super
important faut que j'aie des gens au top
avec moi je respecte je comprends
complètement ce qui s'est passé hier je
sais tu es nerveux c'est la première
fois que je fais un sparring ait mec tu
étais pas là j'étais nerveux mais tu
peux compter sur moi tu peux y aller
pour faire les sacs sacs de frappe j'en
ai plein lassegue
je pense à lui je pense ac
scharbook tu vois je prends des coups
mais je suis pas un sac par contre j'ai
un truc que tu as pas ah ouais j'ai pris
les carreaux je suis retourné sur le
ring et je peux te dire un truc
toi tu as peur tu t'es pas remis dans le
chaos
[Musique]
excusez-moi vrai que vous cherchez le
sparring pour tarik mbarek était gaucher
non mon veston gueule non mais je peux
faire la fausse patte ans et robin hood
texas ont finalement justement j'ai
l'expérience c'est quoi ta carte 49
combats 13 3 33 défaites
c'est pas contre qui on a envie de
matisse
je le connais marvin l'a encore été ce
mari non mais je me suis battu contre
lui à 8 ans il sortait de l'amateur ou a
ici la tuer banon et je sais comment is
by je sais qu'on me tape chercher quoi
comme sparring
t'as combien à 74,75 marché en dessous
je peux monter cherche un sparring
caisse et qui fait pas chier c'est moi
ça faisait là tant mieux ouais je te
promets rien acheté au point
[Applaudissements]